[Music]
the visual experience featuring miss
Kendall Jenner tell us about the Hat
well it's on the family because Kim you
know of course it did on milk and I just
know the girls whole family for such a
long time
oh we had this kind of random moment at
Coachella
we ended up in this car she was
lip-synching to a song and I remember
thinking wow she's got like an inner pop
star inside of her I was thinking I
would love for one of those songs or
somebody to be able to explore that
where they don't always feel like you
know that's their place and so she
really got to kind of come out and play
a bunch of different characters and just
kind of get her little diva on now were
you there to coach her I wasn't I was on
FaceTime
I was on Facebook I wanted her to just
do her thing Nicki Minaj and you its
iconic already I just want to talk about
the split well I had to do it with
something with the lyrics you know what
I stretched a lot so I had to stretch
make sure I could do something fun that
wasn't something that everyone it's
didn't before he was fired by Beyonce I
know you love her she released a visual
album it's completely different than
Beyonce's but absolutely she's an
inspiration to me in all areas
performance Drive balance she's just I
mean she is the queen bee ship but for
just on a real note and it's just such a
nice person
how can you not be inspired by her but
her doing that Justin Bieber you know
Beyonce of course paving the way Justin
Bieber doing his version having Paris
choreograph and all the dancers I just
really enjoyed it as an as a fan and it
makes me listen to songs that I wouldn't
maybe necessarily listen to it's kind of
like a photo album over the last few
years of my life
[Music]
you